now the US has the highest number of
co-ed 19 related deaths in the world
according to Johns Hopkins University
with more than 19,000 600 reported
victims further 783 people have died in
New York that brings a total number of
people who've died there to 8,000 at 627
but Andrew Cuomo says the number of
people admitted to hospital and those in
intensive care is continuing to fall
further Bunco is in New York for hours
and so some very alarming news on the
death rates but perhaps some hope when
it comes to hospital numbers yeah Sophie
these figures are not figures that
country like America would want to have
attached to it yesterday they recorded
2,000 deaths nationwide the first
country in the world to do so they now
as you have said have just overtaken
Italy in the number of deaths recorded
and it will probably be a matter of
hours before they hit the 20,000 mark
the first country globally to have
achieved that as well these are
embarrassing figures for the world's
richest nation embarrassing figures for
a nation that prides itself in an
advanced medical system and yet that is
where we are and despite Donald Trump in
the past having tried to blame others
trying to question the approach made by
different other countries to their
pandemic the United Kingdom has been one
of those he's criticized and the United
States is really struggling with this
now more so than just in New York
although this is where I am still very
much the epicenter New York is still
recording the worst number of cases a
very high death toll again over the past
24 hours that's stable but it's not
really falling below that average of
around 750 deaths a day what is good is
that the number of hospitalizations are
going down the number of people being
admitted to intensive care is going down
the number of people who have been
intubated are going down and so the
curve is definitely flattening we are
starting to see a plateau here over a
number of days it will take some time
before the figures start to really fall
away the other side and it is an effect
of the social distancing measures put in
place there is talk about when that
might be lifted Donald Trump of course
keen to reopen the economy
wants to do it sooner rather than later
he'd originally planned to have it open
by Easter by this weekend that was
always very ambitious he's now
potentially looking at early May but the
New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio has said
schools here will remain closed for the
rest of the academic year so until at
least September and the governor in his
press conference earlier citing comments
made by Winston Churchill towards the
end of World War two said that this is
only the end of the beginning